great meetings all day long um you know
trying to create some meanness this
episode I'll who is going to talk I'm
editing it naturally I'm Tom Geisel
gonna come back like a vegetable and I
see with clarity hustle like my name is
Gary Thomas I've been telling you
accountable celebrities
I'm triple a given a pedigree to mean
and a pleasure my faculty including the
work that I'm doing are the moving
furniture Travis good morning Instagram
McGary
stead of a motivational food or comfort
eclipse want to show
all these guys
female 2 p.m.
[Music]
that's me
you
[Music]
this is something I've spent a lot of
time on because I was going to go right
after it as a media company and this was
it's such a natural for this company so
anyway we should win this it'd be stupid
not to and honestly I think that's the
punchline of this episode which is like
look I think the thing that is really
fascinating about this vlog about being
an executive at this scale is there's
some things that are enormously
predicated on conversations that I can't
share with the world but I can give you
some themes I think the thing that
people need to remember is you're going
to if you're running a business you know
you can be financially based or in the
short term or in the long term think
what a penis for me today is being an
executive is I continue to be proud of
the fact that I make decisions but a
long term because unless I'm going to
sell my business which I'm not they're
always going to be long-term gains right
so why make decisions you know so many
of you are going to run into money for
the first time this year and I'm going
to make one hundred thirty thousand
instead of sixty thousand the first time
and what you're going to do is go buy
stuff you know you've been waiting so
long there's a good way to cut in the
you know the askgaryvee with Eric today
right Henry buddy's car is vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 243 of the
askgaryvee show
Eric wall welcome to the show
we'll see you my man [ __ ] she talks
getting used to patience I've learned
more patient in the last 12 months and
I've had to endure my rule before we go
through phone call and grab sorry there
in the last 12 months now should I get
comfy on the couch yeah I'm some you
intrigued me before we yeah what what
tell me that were had struggle with like
loving every part of the journey or I
put in so much work don't I deserve now
to cash in the answer shirt I thought my
brand was going to launch I thought that
I've done the ten twelve years of living
away you know you're logging 250,000
miles in that as soon as you went out
weirdly and did the videos and all this
not you know dude [ __ ] man [ __ ] you can
cash in anytime you want the problem is
when you cash in cash it and what do I
can write up I mean that the second you
cash in you're taking money out of the
kitty that can be in investing and
you're converting it into something
short earn which is your progress like
do you but uh but one of the missions I
have here is to teach people how to
build big things on the Empire and the
way you be able to build big things is
continue to invest in those things and
so today's themes were very very happy
on how do I and why do I continue invest
in division agendas people came here
state it look like it's all that and
right but then but being a bless someone
who scaled so much in his life it's
about the unscalable scalable to early
strategies infrastructure departments I
mean today was a full day of not being
and you know xx you caught any of the
film of me and Alan the CFO so far is
perfect that meeting in the middle where
the beginning day is very much short
term here's the financial realities
you're dealing with you know can you
afford to invest in everything and the
answer is yes and no and so I think the
balance of where you're going and what
you want in
short-term versus a long-term it is a
difficult one for all of us but I do
implore all of you that are watching
I implore all of you who are watching
the more you can invest in the long-term
the more you will win you know you know
do will recall a little bit to Tony
Robbins is quote from a scary day about
the market here 80% of those Corrections
never become a bear market they all
crept back just like last year but if
you sold you look cool but then let's
look at the crash crash is happening
every five years on average we've got to
eat without one another not were
different and you're right to be someone
prepare food but while you're preparing
there's opportunity that's happening
because first of all every bear market
lasts on average a year go down 33
percent but you know lose 33 unless you
sell especially one thing I want people
to hear in two centuries of American
business every single bear market was
followed by bull market so you remember
2008 people want 50% this is what about
this one or 69 this is with you know if
you take the money out of the market or
what a long term you tend to lose if you
decide to make more profit in your
businesses here because you want to buy
something those are dollars you can't
use to build your foundation and I think
a lot of you are building very small
businesses or smaller than your ambition
is because you need too much in the
short term you're taking too much out in
the short term and so I continue to be a
very um passionate and very very focused
on investing in the long term at the
expense of some of the short-term
luxuries maybe I can't have some of the
things that I want but you know to
someone you say like Gary be like it's
cool to see you take a comedy scene in a
plane or it's super funny to not see you
be fancy it's because I'm investing my
future you know
yes if I go private jet for 15,000 set
of economy for 500 at 15,000 that I can
invest in the longer term and so instead
of having a private jet I end up with
the New York Jets and so what's really
important about you guys following this
journey I hope I hope my legacy is that
you know not only am I talking in this
land about long-term investment but you
always be able to actually physically
watch this over the next five 10 15
years of what long-term investment means
in relationships that my man babbit here
in strategies of a lot of the behind the
closed door meetings where today I made
decisions that are not in my best
interest short-term and really in just
the RAM of my life
financially professionally as a dude
really speaks to I don't charge you guys
for stuff I don't want your short term
dollars I want your season tickets to
the New York Jets one day
[Music]
you
[Music]